all right so someone wanted to know is
it possible to reverse insulin
resistance and how long does it take so
this video is for that person first of
all what is insulin resistance
it's a condition whereby the cells are
no longer absorbing insulin so insulin
is being rejected okay and so in the
receptor for insulin it's just not
receiving insulin anymore the
consequence of that is this without
insulin the cells can't get fuel they
can't get nutrition so they're starving
they're hungry and you're creating
carbohydrates there's a little signal
sent back to the pancreas because it's
not getting absorbed inside the cell
that tells the pancreas hey we don't
have enough insulin make more so the
pancreas makes more and more insulin so
an average person with insulin
resistance has five to seven times more
than normal the problem with this is
that this high level of insulin creates
damage in the body also the fact that
it's not getting into the body that well
it can raise your blood sugar so you've
got high blood sugars because the
purpose of insulin is to lower the blood
sugar so we have this dynamic of the
hormone trying to do its work but it
can't so then it can't control the blood
sugar so it can start going higher and
higher and higher yeah at the same time
the cells are starving they're hungry
and if you have insulin resistance in
the brain then if they can't get fuel
they die that's Alzheimer's okay so
that's really what it is so what causes
insulin resistance the overexposure of
insulin okay okay will cause that the
chronic consumption of carbs and eating
too frequent okay frequent meals and
snacking how do we fix this problem
well you just reverse the process and
you do prolong absence of insulin so we
just avoid the triggering of insulin
over a period of time because here's the
problem if you don't fix this you're not
going to get weight loss so all those
workouts that you're doing are a waste
of time all the diets you're doing don't
really work and you're going to be
hungry all the time so you're not going
to be able to stick to it now based on
my opinion it takes between three to
eight plus months to reverse insulin
resistance but the cool thing is you can
also reverse pre-diabetes and type 2
diabetes now my guess is that doing keto
is responsible for maybe twenty to
thirty percent of the improvements
intermittent fasting is responsible for
about 60% of the improvements we add
those together we get about eighty
percent but if you do the healthy
version of keto within intermittent fasting
together you can get 90 plus percent
results why because the healthy version
of keto itself supplies the key
nutrients okay
zinc vitamin D chromium potassium
magnesium but B vitamins to help speed
up the process and if you want to
enhance the speed up your results you
would add these things exercise reduce
your stress increase sleeping certain
supplements to take more of certain
nutrients that target the beta cells of
the pancreas that are involved in insulin
resistance and the way that you know
that insulin resistance is going away
you can do a test called
Homa IR okay but honestly I would just
look at these six things okay number one
is your hunger going away can you go
longer between meals without eating how
about your belly fat is it disappearing
that means the inside of the fat around
the organs is going away especially the
liver fat as well is your blood pressure
going down now here's the thing when you
have high insulin or high sugars the
arteries get really really stiff and
when you do healthy keto and
intermittent fasting with I would also
recommend more vitamin D with this you
can improve blood pressure but sometimes
it takes up to a year to get this under
control
next one good blood Sugar's now for most
people you're going to see change
immediately now if you've been a
diabetic for many many years and talking
type 2 it could take up to a year to
really get this blood sugar under
control number five
no dawn phenomena the dawn phenomena is
this when you wake up in the morning you
didn't
and your blood sugar is high that just
means that you're in the transition
phase of adapting to ketosis and you
still have insulin resistance so if you
have this and then it goes away which it
will over time that means your insulin
resistance is much much better and
number six you have a lot more energy
that's a real good indicator that it's
working and I'm gonna I'm gonna add
number seven which is you're satisfied
when you eat so maybe before when you
had insulin resistance you eat and you
just don't feel fulfilled now you do of
course you're gonna have to eat the
right foods but the feeling of being
satisfied after you eat tells me that
the nutrition is going into the cell
it's working that means that you no
longer have that resistance because with
instant resistance that blocks the
nutrients going in the  it's hard
to feel satisfied with food anyway
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next video if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos